من البيت الأبيض إلى قائد بيت الكلب،
تمت إزالة الراعي الألماني لبايدن من أراضي العاصمة، وقد
تعرض أول K9 لحوادث عض أكثر
مما تم الإبلاغ عنه سابقًا، وتقول المصادر
إنها تخلق بيئة عمل خطيرة
لموظفي البيت الأبيض حتى
تحذير الخدمة السرية  العملاء
لتجنب مناطق معينة لمحاولة الابتعاد عن
الطريق وعدم التفاعل،
أصبح من الواضح أن هذا العدد كان
أكبر بكثير في الواقع، كان هناك عشرات من العضات
لكل من الخدمة السرية ولكن أيضًا لأعضاء
موظفي الإقامة السابقين
وغيرهم  الأشخاص الذين يعملون هنا في
قائد البيت الأبيض ليسوا موجودين حاليًا في
حرم البيت الأبيض بينما يتم تقييم الخطوات التالية.
تجدر الإشارة إلى أن
القائد بايدن هو أحد أفراد عائلة بايدن
ويسافر معهم في
عطلات نهاية الأسبوع إلى ديلاوير إلى كامب ديفيد
وهذا غير واضح حقًا.  أين هو الآن وما هي
الخطوات التالية،
هل يمكنهم إيجاد حل للسيطرة على هذه المشكلة